in the three months since Hurricane
Maria hundreds of thousands of people
living in Puerto Rico left to the US
mainland more than 200 15,000 arrived in
Florida since October 3rd when the state
began counting one study estimates more
than 470 thousand people will leave
Puerto Rico over two years many need
help to make the transition David beg
know is that the multi-agency resource
center at Orlando International Airport
that is actually the first stop for many
of the arrivals David good morning
Nour good morning when we arrived here
at the disaster Resource Center the
first person we saw was Maria she's
right there on her phone she was here
with her two boys and her mother they
arrived on a midnight flight from San
Juan with no friends or family here and
no place to go they are waiting until
9:00 a.m. when this disaster Resource
Center opens it's a one stop shop where
she can find everything she needs here
they'll give you a help and they'll give
you a hope Araceli Baez Martinez and her
husband Jose Rodriguez found hope in
this hotel room this is home for now
Araceli z-- arrived in Orlando with $4
in her pocket
did you lose everything we first met the
couple at the Orlando Airport she's
heartbroken because she misses her
Island
the woman interpreting is Betsy Frances
Cheney of the Hispanic Federation what
we're seeing here is that you know we
have a crisis in Puerto Rico and now
it's moving to Central Florida the
Federation is a nonprofit organization
which helps Puerto Ricans arriving here
find housing register to vote and learn
English folks that are coming here and
the families are running into
difficulties you know to find a house to
find a job to you know
register their children if they don't
have the documents more than 1 million
Puerto Ricans already live in Florida in
2016 the state had the second-highest
puerto rican population in the u.s.
after new york you've stayed and how
many hotels altogether Elliott Pena and
his wife and two stepdaughters arrived
in Florida in September 24th four days
after Hurricane Maria made landfall
they've spent 72 days in a hotel room
with double beds
and like inside four walls it's not
helping my stress your sanity
exactly seventeen-year-old Jadine rolled
on is one of about 2,500 Hurricane Maria
survivors who've enrolled in the Orange
County school system she's debating
going to college here in Florida many
universities are offering Puerto Rican
students in-state tuition
she's already been offered a scholarship
through job opportunities I think it's
better over here what makes you
emotional
I'm the stress you know it's been high
what we're going for a de sel ease she's
considering returning to Puerto Rico
eventually once it rebuilds and things
are back to normal she has the you know
the dream of going back there is a
political component to this that a lot
of people are talking about Florida is a
prized swing state consider this in last
year's presidential election the Latinos
went to the Democrat the Latino vote
went to the Democrats president Trump
won the state of Florida but by a
hundred thousand votes Puerto Ricans are
eligible to register to vote and if
200,000 people who have come here decide
to vote what could that do in next
year's midterm election
bianna of course David we still think of
the election of 2000 thank you